quand j'étais après dans les mains tu
feras Benjamin Castaldi
dans mes mains tu sors
[Applaudissements]
voilà voilà où on est la France on bouge
pas mal voilà
il est temps que Sarkozy mette un peu
d'ordre à tout ça mon ami avec
quand je taperai dans mes mains tu seras
bien Lescure
Xavier Couture je crois que c'est demain
ou un besoin d'augmentation
une famille nombreuse à nourrir
et ça va être effectivement dans les
prochains jours
ça c'est pour vous Omar quand je taperai
dans mes mains tu seras Jean-Marie Le
Pen le soir du 1er tour
l'homme est frais du film quoi le
pénible
vous êtes un homme malsain
un technocrate vous connaissez pas la
France métallo acculé de dettes sur un
non
[Applaudissements]
mais tu seras Michael Jackson
il est décédé ce matin se permettre de
se moquer des morts
ce matin
si vous voulez que Félicien se battent à
main nue contre un grizzly taper un par
contre si vous voulez que Leslie se
fasse prendre par le Grizzly
ouais
c'est ça
quand j'étais après dans les matchs
attention
quand je t'apprenne dans mes mains tu
seras Fred
[Applaudissements]
imiterai dans le mal tu seras Omar
bonsoir
Laurent c'est à VOUS attention
quand je taperai dans mes mains vous
serez
Thierry Ardisson
le nouveau Thierry Ardisson le pote de
Guy Bedos j'accueille mon ami de
toujours Guy Bedos
[Musique]
ez-vous été un pouce bleu